In the last video, I touched
on the core weakness of
fractional reserve banking and
that's the idea of the bank
run-- where if you have a bunch
of banks and they've all
lent out 90% of their reserves--
let's say that
here's all my banks-- Bank One,
Bank Two, Bank Three--
and you could have
a ton of banks.
I mean, you could imagine you
go all the way to Bank 100.
The problem with a bank run is
if just even one bank all of a
sudden isn't able to give its
depositors its money-- so it
is illiquid-- and we'll reserve
judgment as to whether
it is truly insolvent, but it
really just doesn't have the
money to give it to depositors,
then all of the
depositors of all of the other
banks get scared and run over
to the banks and ask for
their money back.
And by definition, in a
fractional reserve banking
system, these guys only have
10% of their deposits as
reserves, 10% reserves.
So if more than 10% of the
people ask for their money,
they're all going
to be illiquid.
Then you're going to have
just an all-out panic.
You're going to have
an all-out panic of
the financial system.
As soon as any of these guys'
loans come due-- so let me
draw one of their balance
sheets-- let's assume that
they were actually good
investors, which is a big
assumption, but let's say
that their balance
sheets look like this.
Here's all of the deposits that
they owe to people-- to
me and you.
That's their liabilities.
They have 10% of their assets
as actual currency reserves.
And then the rest is loans
out to businesses
and whatever else.
And that's an asset because
businesses owe them something.
And what's going to happens--
as soon as there's a panic,
everyone wants their
money out.
The reserves are depleted
very quickly.
And then these guys sit there
waiting for their money.
Essentially it shuts
down the bank.
As soon as these loans mature--
maybe this guy owed
his money in a year.
Then they're going to say, just
give me the money back.
I'm not going to renew the loan
even though you have a
good business.
And so everyone's going to want
their money back and the
whole financial system's going
to break down and credit is
going to freeze.
And this is a huge problem.
Remember, this could be just
because by one bad actor who
couldn't manage their
liquidity properly.
Even worse, it could be caused
just by one panicky
withdrawer.
There's doesn't even have
to be a bad actor.
It could just be some fear that
enters the system-- and
even for a completely legitimate
bank-- and I'll use
legitimate in quotations
because we're assuming
legitimate-- because some
would debate whether
fractional reserve banking
is legitimate.
But even if this is a completely
up-and-up bank, if
for whatever reason more than
10% of their deposits get
scared, then all of a sudden
they'll be illiquid and you'll
be in this all-out
panic condition.
Now I talked in the last video,
some of the things that
have been engineered to
fix this problem.
So these are the fixes.
The first one is to have a
banker of last resort, a
lender of last resort.
And that's our central bank--
or the Federal reserve bank.
And they'll never run out of
reserves, because these
reserves can be borrowed from
them and all these are, are
IOUs from the Federal reserve.
So what the Federal reserve
does-- and I've talked about
this in the past-- let's say
that their balance sheet
currently looks like this.
Let's say that this is their
current liabilities.
These are their current
assets.
And their current
liabilities are
essentially going to be IOUs.
These are going to be their
reserve notes, but let's say
someone else comes and says,
hey, federal reserve, lend me
some money.
So what they're going to do is
that they're going to print
some-- so these are Federal
reserve notes.
And then they're going to just
create an offsetting liability
and they have no
reserve limits.
Let me make it a new color just
to ease the monotony.
So they'll have this
corresponding notes
outstanding liability and
they're going to give those
notes to you.
They're going to give those
notes to the bank that's in a
desperate situation if
it couldn't borrow
from any other bank.
And so the Federal reserve
balance sheet will
now look like this.
This is what it looked
like before.
It has these new notes
outstanding and now this will
say-- instead of federal reserve
notes in its vaults,
it'll now have this little thing
on its books called loan
to the bank, loan to this guy
right here, which is an asset
because he owes him something.
And there's no limit to
which the Federal
reserve could do this.
Obviously there might be some
kind of implicit limit.
If they keep doing this
arbitrarily, people might not
accept these Federal
reserve notes as
actually carrying value.
So that's probably the main
limiting concern.
And I'll probably talk more in
future videos on other things
that are kind of keeping the
Federal reserve from just
doing this willy-nilly, but the
general idea is that they
never run out.
So this is one idea-- lender of
last resort, but not even
the Federal reserve wants to
keep doing this because what
if this guy is essentially
insolvent?
If these loans are actually
going bad, then there's no
reason that even the central
bank should actually be
lending to this guy.
They shouldn't be lending
to this guy.
So let's say the Federal reserve
looks at this guy's
books and say, you know what?
These loans are really
worthless.
I'm not going to lend
more money to you.
What I'm going to do is take
you into receivership.
And I haven't even talked
about what that is.
That's the second fix.
The second fix is to have this
notion of insurance, of
deposit insurance.
So if a bank just has a
liquidity problem-- it's a
good bank-- it just ran out of
reserves and no other bank is
willing to lend to it-- which
you might debate whether it's
even a good bank if the other
banks aren't willing to lend
to it-- then it can go to the
discount window at the Federal
reserve and borrow some
reserve notes.
Now, in the situation where even
that's not good enough
and the bank is essentially out
of business, it had been
paying the FDIC a little bit of
money-- the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation-- a little
bit of money-- I mean,
probably a lot of money by an
individual's point of view,
but a little bit of money from
a bank's point of view-- and
it's a fraction of a percent--
a little bit of money every
year so that it could tell its
depositors, look, even in the
situation that our bank goes
bust, the Federal reserve is
going to pay you directly.
These are FDIC bank accounts.
The Federal reserve will make
you whole completely,
regardless of what happens
to the banks.
Now this, to me, is a big fix.
I mean, I'll tell you right now,
all of my savings right
now are in Federal deposit
insured-- FDIC
insured-- bank accounts.
This might sound great to the
depositor, but what's the side
effect on the banking system?
Let me draw all of
my banks again.
So I have Bank One, I have Bank
Two, I have Bank Three, I
have Bank Four.
Now, they are all
FDIC insured.
They pay some small fraction of
a percentage every year so
that they can tell their
depositors, look, if we ever
go bust, if we ever blow up
for whatever reason, your
deposits are 100% safe.
And what's going to happen?
This will solve the bank
run problem, right?
Let's say for whatever reason
this guy runs out of reserves
or he goes bankrupt--
let's say that
this guy goes bankrupt.
In the old situation, before the
insurance, everyone else
is going to get scared
and you're going
to have a bank run.
They're going to ask for their
money and there's just not
going to be enough reserves
because they only keep a
fraction of the reserves.
That's what fractional reserve
banking is, but now everyone's
going to feel comfortable,
like, you know what?
Everything is backed by the
Federal reserve, which can
print as many notes is
it wants so I'm just
going to sit pretty.
So this does solve the
bank run problem.
And so you might say, this
doesn't make it an unstable
equilibrium any more-- which
is kind of true, but
what does this do?
All of these guys are
now FDIC insured.
I'm equally willing to give my
money to any of these guys.
So I'm going to essentially
going to give my money to the
guy who gives me the highest
interest. And I've actually
done that with my personal
accounts.
I've gone and I've seen which
bank provides the highest
interest and I've ignored how
they're investing their
money-- I mean, otherwise I'd
be pretty suspicious about a
bank offering more interest
because they're probably doing
something risky, but now I don't
care because I know it's
FDIC insured and even if that
bank blows up, I'm going to
get all my money back.
So I might as well give my
deposit to the bank with the
highest interest.
Now based on what you saw in
that last video, which is the
bank that's going to be giving
the highest interest?
What's going to be
the bank that's
taking on the most risk?
So once again, when you give
this relatively cheap
insurance to all of these banks
and all of these banks
can attract money much easier by
paying this insurance-- if
they didn't have this insurance,
they would have to
pay much more.
Let's say this insurance
is 0.1% per year.
If they didn't have this
insurance, they would have to
pay much more than 0.1% per
year to the depositor in
interest to make up for the risk
that they're taking on,
that they're not being backed
by the government.
So it's a really good deal
for the depositor.
Let's put it this way.
When you give a deposit to
a bank, you're lending
money to the bank.
So your checking deposit rate--
so let me write this
down-- your checking deposit
interest rate is the same
thing as the bank's borrowing
cost, right?
When I go to some bank and
they're paying me 2% a year,
that's the bank's borrowing
cost. They're the same thing.
Now if the bank didn't have FDIC
insurance, it wouldn't
have to pay 0.1% a year, but it
would have to give me more
interest. It would have to pay
me 3% or 4%, probably more,
because I'd say this
is a risky bank--
or it's more risky.
Any bank would be more risky
than someone who can
print out the notes.
So it would have to pay more,
but now it can just pay 0.1% a
year or whatever the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation
pays it, but it's going to lower
to FDIC, but the main
side effect of this is it's
going to lower what it has to
pay the depositors because the
depositors say, this is a lot
safer than what I thought.
So it's going to lower
borrowing costs by
much more than 0.1%.
So it's a really good deal
for the bank and it's an
especially good deal for the
ultra-risky banks who might
have to pay a little bit more,
but because they can now do
super duper risky things.
You say, hey, but this
is insurance.
The Federal Deposit Insurance
Corporation isn't stupid.
It should just charge more
for riskier banks.
But I guess the rebuttal to
that is that's easier said
than done because when times are
good, like in the '20s or
during the housing bubble,
you get hidden risk.
So you don't know who's
taking on the risk.
It's usually the person who's
getting the highest returns,
but if they're always good for
it, you don't see it and that
person just looks
like a genius.
And then when times are
bad, that guy blows
up, but guess what?
He's not on the line for it.
It's the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation, who all
along was probably
undercharging for that insurance.
I want to make one last
point about this.
It's called insurance.
It's the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation.
And I want to point out the
difference between financial
insurance-- and you could
watch my video on credit
default swaps, which is another
form of financial
insurance-- between financial
insurance and what we normally
associate with insurance.
If I have car insurance-- let's
say I'm a car insurance
person and I agree-- let's say
that they are Driver One--
let's say I have a bunch of
drivers-- so Driver One,
Driver Two, Driver Three,
Driver Four.
And I know that in any given
year, they each have a 10%
chance of an accident.
That's a lot higher than
reality, but we'll make the
numbers easy.
And if there is an accident,
it will cost me $10,000.
So I could go to Driver One and
say, look, there's a 10%
chance you're going to
have an accident.
It would cost $10,000
if you do.
So I'm going to charge
you-- the fair
price would be $1,000.
I'll charge you $1,100.
I'll charge $1,100 just so I
can make a little bit of a
profit, right?
What you would charge is $1,000
if you wanted to break
even, but I'll charge $1,100--
and I might do this more than
just four drivers.
I might do it with
4,000 drivers.
So on average in any given
year-- let's say I have one
million drivers-- in any given
year, how much am I
going to bring in?
I'm going to bring in a million
times $1,100, which
is-- I'm going to get $1.1
billion in input, or in
revenue, from people paying
their premiums. And how much
am I going to have to pay out?
Well, roughly 10% if you believe
these statistics are
going to have an accident.
So that means that 100,000 are
Each of those 100,000
accidents are
going to cost me $10,000.
$10,000 times $100,000.
I'm going to have to pay out $1
billion for the accidents.
So I will net every year-- if my
actuaries did their job, I
will net $100 million
every year.
And this works out pretty good
assuming these statistics are
right and people are willing to
pay the premium because if
you have enough drivers-- like
a million drivers-- the
statistics really hold.
In any given year, the chance
of 20% of the drivers having
an accident is very,
very, very-- almost
infinitesimally small.
It's almost zero.
And one driver having an
accident doesn't make it more
or less likely that another
driver will have an accident
when you're talking
about on the order
of a million drivers.
And that's true of health
insurance and everything else.
It's just purely probabilistic
and if you have enough people
insured, the statistics
can actually hold up.
Now with financial
insurance, you
have a different situation.
You might say, look, in any
given year, on average, the
FDIC might say, look, only-- I
don't know-- one out of out of
1,000 banks fail.
So there's a 0.1% chance
of failure.
Of course it'll capture back
some money because it'll have
some assets on average.
But the reality is that when
times go bad, the bank
failures tend to be correlated
because they're all
interlinked.
And I've done a lot-- one
might be lending to some
business that's dependent on
some business that this guy's
lending to.
The whole financial system
is all linked up.
So the failures aren't-- they
all correlate with each other.
They're not independent
events.
So if one bank fails, it's much
more likely that other
banks are going to fail all
at the same time and we're
experiencing that right now.
So you can't really follow the
insurance model because the
statistics really don't apply.
You can do this insurance model
when each of the events
that you're insuring are
uncorrelated, but when all the
events that you're insuring are
likely to all happen at
the same time, what you're going
to have is-- when times
are good, you're going to see a
much lower kind of loss rate
and then when times are bad, all
of your guys are going to
blow up and you're essentially
on the hook
for all these people.
We see that right now and the
FDIC is actually-- it's going
to have to go back to Congress,
I'm 100% sure, and
ask for more money and it's we
the taxpayers that are going
to be on the line for
this type of thing.